こんにちははめ社長ですそしてあ山田です
こんばんは山田高幸さんですよろしくお
願いしますお願いし
ます何ですかそのそういうテンションいや
謝罪動画ですか今日はですね僕よく心霊
スポットに行くんですけれどもはい山田
さんは心霊スポットとか行かれたことあり
ますかないです今までゼゼですね霊感とか
はありますか分かりません意識したこと
ないんで道するということではいどんなん
ですか僕も霊感はないんですようんないの
でそのもう怖いもの見たさと言いますか
うん逆に見たいからついつい足を運んで
しまうみたいなので結構心霊スポットの
動画を出してしまってるんですけれども
山田さんが心霊スポットに行ったことが
ないということで今日はです
ね京都のとあるスポット
に山田高幸さんと行きたいと思い
ますはいいいんですか初めてを頂いて
しまっていい
よありがとうございます怖いの得意です
か脅かされるのはあんまり得意ではない
ですけどああお化け屋敷とかそういうのは
ちょっとうんそうですね心霊スポットとか
は決してそういうなんかドッキリとかでも
なく何か脅してくるとかでもないのでうん
そうですね動け屋敷とは違いますねはい
そこはちょっとま1つ安心していただける
とというはい部分でありますがま僕も今
までいろんなところに行ってきたんです
けれどもやっぱ何が起きるか分からないの
ではいそこはちょっと1つこう覚悟と言い
ますか
はいガチですねガチです
え12時23分でございますああちょうど
日付が変わったぐらい1番怖い時間に今日
2人で
行きたいと思いますよろしくお願いします
お願いします今日行くところは小野坂
トンネルというはいトンネルでございます
トンネルはいはい噂によると白い服を着た
女性の霊が見えると言われていますうん
はいそもそもトンネルは山を超えるために
作られているものなんですけれどもま
トンネルができる前山を超える時山越は
山賊の存在等があってかなり危険でしたと
うん中にはま遭難だったり命を落とす人も
いてトンネルの近く山の近くは曰がつく
ことが多いそうですうんはいでこの今から
行く大坂トンネルという場所なんです
けれども京都の中心から上岡の方へ抜けて
いくトンネルはいで首塚大明人という首塚
がありましてほ首塚大明人が近くにあると
いうことで霊の影響をもに受けていると
いううん説がありますなるほど
で近くにはですね他にも心霊スポットが
結構トンネルの付近にあるらしくて首塚大
名人がかなり強い場所らしいんですようん
そこの影響を受けた多くの心霊スポットの
1つそれが井野さトンネルとはい言われて
ますめっちゃトラックとるなうんなんかあ
あれなんかそういう現象が起きてるのあ
いやこれは多分普通のトラックですそんな
にだって普通トラック通らなく
ねこの時間は通らないと思いますねなんか
あんじゃ
ないなるほどバイクもあババクこんな世
なかあバイクまた本当ちょっとバイク多め
です
ね車車うんあヤシだ青いLEDついてます
ねうん下が青かったあるかもねやっぱね
車通り多いところの心理スポット結構
珍しいなと思っててうんいつも行くところ
結構静かな場所が多いんですそうだよねな
のでちょっと正直僕今のところうん今日は
割と大丈夫かなって気持ちが本当に
トンネルは強いんですけどだけどこんなさ
トラックとかさバイクとかさ二者とか
さ通らないじゃん普通ま時間的にもそう
ですねなんかあるかもしれ
ないち
怖いですねまでもて行こ行こうかはい行き
ましょうか行ってみ行って山田さんは幽霊
は信じますか信じるかどうかというよりは
タクシーも通タクシーも通ります黒塗りの
車を通りますこんな時間にタクシー通る
か結構京都駅から離れましたけどねそうだ
ねまあまあ
まあまあまあ何が起きてもねそれはもう
全て受けませ私はああなるほどうんやっ
たら遅くないあの車あああれえあれとああ
バイクかバイクですね遅い
バイク遅くない燃料少ないんですか遅く
ないあのバイクおない徐行してますねもう
なん
なら止まりそうじゃ
ねど
使え山田さんとか見たことあります見た
ことはないよ感じたこととか1回だけある
え1回だけ18ぐらいの時かな1818
って何年前だ42
だ22年前トラックあ
トラックなんか差し方もやっぱおかしかっ
たいつもと違うわ俺も釣はずのところうん
なんかあのそこの家はあのよく結構みんな
が集まる家だったんだけどもそういうなん
かね霊感強いみたいな人がやっぱいたわけ
よでその人がこの家は結構良くないよって
うんいうこと言ってたなんか霊道って聞い
たことあるあ例が通るはいはいはいがあ
るって言っててでまそん時別にそういうの
も信じないしさいやいやいやみたいな感じ
だったんだけど朝方まだ結構こう話し込ん
でたはいリビングの俺ソファーでこうやっ
て横になってたのねでそいつはソファーが
こっちとこっちにあっってこれそこに座せ
たのはいで喋ってる時
にこっちの角からビュンって何かが俺の
こっち右下の方にごめんね今揺れちゃった
けどあいビュンって来たわけよでそれで
うってなったのしたらそいつが今通った
ねええちょちょっとえ何が例霊が通ったて
だけやだなと思った感じたくないじゃん
うん
どっちからどっちの方に通ったのっこっち
からこっちの方に通っ
た感じだわえ生き物とかではなかったん
ですか家の中のマンション目には見えて
ない何かを感じ
た2人て2人とも感じてるのやばいすね
それ
うんそういうのが経験があったかこ回
なるほどですねでもそれぐらいだしうん
もうそっからね22年間は立ってるわけだ
から
はい衰えてると思そああ例のそういう殺
能力みたいなものがもうただの中年だから
いやいやいやいや日本の宝です中肉中勢の
中年いやいや関係ないですさ大丈夫
ですいや山田さんとシネスポット来る日が
来るなんて夢にも思ってなかった
ですうん俺もそんなことすると思って
なかったの
すいませんな初めてをいただきまし
たやろやろはいじゃあ行きましょうか
早速ああイケメン
だイケメン
[音楽]
だ行き
ましょう
行きましょう山田
さん大丈夫ですか行く行行き
ましょうこれ持ってってもいいあ持ってき
ましょう持ってかない方が雰囲気出る
トンネルは結構ライトあるみたいです
じゃあいいか今も置いてきましょうほと車
でも多いですねここら辺寒いねそして
あんな
に暑かったんだ
よ夜はやっぱ冷えますねああそこですそこ
ですあもう使われてないてことだってこれ
ほら
左急がれてるのあ本当だ車は入んなそう
ですね昔はここが道路だったけど今は
こっち左に道路を作ったということかなあ
そうですね
[音楽]
多分分けるか待って待って待って待って
今なんか下行って
まヤンキーヤンキーだ最悪だヤンキーは
怖い夜は静かにしてほしいヤンキーは怖い
よほら今なんかキャってバイクが多いそう
いう声が人じゃなかった時ですよねうん
じゃあちょっと入っていきたいと思い
ますえなんかでも明るいじゃんこれ明る
すぎません明いから何も怖くないでした
こん大丈夫すね
うんうわあでも風が
冷たいあ意外と民度
がいいですねもっとひどいところ落書き
だらけだったりするんでうんじゃげてはい
はいこれがあるもんああ非常用の電話うん
なんかあったらだこれボタンもあるしの
スイッチもあるから大丈夫でしょ今見て
これこの等
感覚絶対大丈夫だこれいっぱいあるこれは
大丈夫か
うん大丈夫ですか怖いですか怖くないだっ
て明るいそうそうですよね
うんあすごい
えいやいやいやビビりすぎだそうですね
大丈夫めっちゃ明るいじゃん
明るいなあでも明るいのな逆に撮影的には
ありがたいんですけどね
うん逆になんかほらこの感じちょっと幽霊
とかっていうよりさうんちょっとほら
サイコキラー的なうんうんうんなんかね
スタンリーキューブリックの世界観みたい
な感ですよキューリーうんそうだねでもさ
ちょっとここまで来てあ後ろ見えてるね
これで
さめっちゃ人走ってきたら怖いねいやまず
か明るいからこそだ後ろもちゃんと見える
ようにしとこうあそうですねこしとここ
これこうなるとちょっと怖いでしょいつ
来るかわか怖いですこれでさふと俺がさ
ちょっとこうなった瞬間に
さ人いたらやばいですねねでも安心ですわ
あそうですね暗いよりかあの
YouTuberと一緒にいてずっとほら
トンネルだからうん仕込み用がないバって
うえとか出てくることできない山田さん僕
それはしないすさすがに疑うとか信用問題
とかじゃなくてそれなんかや
エンターテイメントじゃないまそうですね
のために
そうさあさんやりがちじゃないまそうです
ね仕掛ける時は仕掛けますねまだ真ん中
行ってないでなんでこんな
なんか何これ何です
かコケ見てきてちょっとあ分かりまし
たこれなん
だなんか局所的に緑色くなってますねそこ
と
[音楽]
かコケコケですか
ね
[音楽]
ケコかいやなんかここは山田さんここ
大丈夫です多分余裕でしょここ余裕です
ずっと余裕だよちょうど真ん中ぐらいだね
そうだねこの感じとあそうですね一緒
ぐらいですねうんもとかしないですよ
ねこれちらちらちらちらや
[音楽]
さことに知っ
てる意外と行けますね山田さん多分
スポ
え木だ
た木だたなんでこんなところに確かにどう
やって気が入ってきただろうねいやなんか
車の通りも多いから音もそんな怖くない
です
ねうん風流だよ沈むも泣いていてうんうん
秋ですね
うんえ何これ
え何それて
ない何これ
ていうかそそっち右見てもっわ本当
[音楽]
だ垂れた後とかないです
ねどっから
てけどもう出口
だ本当
だいや山さうんここチレす当たり前だここ
チレす当たり前だよ怖かったねいやいや
全然もう明るすぎますし車も多いしうんで
来てると思ってんだここは大丈夫すねうん
何もないあ出口まで来まし
たいや山田さんこれ
うん大丈夫すここうん明るはい体感で
分かりますこれ大丈夫なとこですうん山田
さん
ねここちょっと余裕だったのでもう1箇所
行ってもいいですもちろんどこ行っても
余裕だよ強いうんじゃあ
次先ほどもお話に出たんですけどもうん
首塚大明人はいはいここら辺の心霊
スポットの元凶と言われている首塚大名人
に行ってみたいと思いますき
ましょう首塚はい鬼の総大将の主点同時の
首があると言われて
ますはい主点同時知ってます聞いたこと
あるめっちゃ強いんですようんで京都は
結界があるって言われてるんですよ京都で
京都の中心部に主点同時の怨念を持ち込ま
ないため
に血界のすぐ外うんに神社を設け
てそこに四天同時の首を神としてこう祭っ
てあるのが首塚大人らしいですうんま色々
あるわけよねそうですねちゃんと歴史ね
そのなんか視点同時がかなりやばいらしく
て首塚大ミュズの他にも周りの心理
スポットに影響を与えていると言われて
いるぐらいうんこのトンネルも祖先はその
首塚大明人の影響を受けた場所の1個
レベルうんの大元となる首塚大名人に今
から行ってみたいと思いますやば
そう結構
やばい行き
ましょうええ
えなん
で天気が半分消えました12時47分
時間じゃないかなあんまり関係なさそうな
タイミング
です戻ろうか戻りましょうか
うんなんで暗くなったん
だ全然さっきと違いますよさっと戻ろう
そうですね
うんさっと戻りましょう
かでざさと戻りましょうか
何何僕ですか
あ待っ
[音楽]
[拍手]
て
さ
大丈夫何してるんですか大丈夫大丈夫です
けど1人にしないでえ待て本当に戻んなく
なりましたね
ライトトンネル
の久々
にこんなに走っ
た全力ダシ
を100mの下に結構な距離でしたよ本当
にトンネルの照明が半分消えましたね突然
うん半端な時間にねその首が大名に行きま
すって言った瞬間ですよ大丈夫かこ行って
こない方がいいぞって来るなよっ
てことかもしれない
うんまちょっとだけ行ってみ
ましょう
行くいいよ全然俺は大丈夫先っぽだけあい
ここ行こあ行きましょうはいというわけで
え首塚大名人に行きたいと思い
ますなんか全然さっきと違いますね暗い
真っ暗思って道がもう街灯が1つもない
がっつりがっつり照らしてますよこれで
ですね結構歩くっぽいですね10分ぐらい
歩くと首塚大名人が見えてくるらしいです
ということはあまゆっっくり歩てると15
分かかっちゃうからあそうですね
あとちょっと早めで歩こうかあちょっと
早めで
うん僕は全然ゆっくりでも大丈夫
ですは全然大丈夫けあ本当ですか楽しん
でるからねあ良かったです楽しんで
いただけるのであれば何よりですはいま
もしなんか不審者が来たらもうこのライト
でやっちゃうから俺あお願いします見
ください見ください何ああ楽書きねああ
これ何それもなんか開いてないていうか
これ立ち入り禁止のテープ貼ってあるの
珍しいね窓ないですよこれ
うん不法陶器
禁止うわあなんかヤンキーとか溜まってそ
うっすねヤンキーが来るのが一番やだもう
リアルな方でです
うん後ろにばやばなんすかなんすかなんす
かなんすか山さんヤンキーがいたら怖いね
ああ山田さんさすがに僕も叫びますようん
ななんだこのお家
[音楽]
も人住んでるのかいや住んでないだろな窓
が開いてるもんだっ
て山田さん怖いですかうん大丈夫よあ
良かった
ですいや暗すぎるなあなんかね本当廃墟
みたいなんですよねあここもすごいですね
なんて読むんだ丁寧のネとかですか
ねなんか作られてたんだろうなあやめだし
[音楽]
たよしもうちょっとありそうですね道がゆ
じゃんあ本当だ電気ついてるよ人は
いらっしゃいますねうん車も止まってる
もんじゃあ大丈夫か明道来ました
ねあ水大人あ左ですねうん
行こうこ
感じうん網が張ってあり
ます何だと思いますかこれどういうことだ
と思いますこれはあれですねあの動物が
来るんでそうですよ追い払うためにCDと
か置いてあるやつですねイノシシとか鹿と
かはいはいはいそういうのが
ね来る可能性がある
とでももほら人の生活権ではあるようん
そうです建物が立ってるからあと道も暗い
んですけどちゃんとしっかりしてるんです
よね舗装されてるね
うんさっきの家のね電気ついて窓開いてて
その人が来たら怖いねああそうですねあら
やってんだつってびっくりし
た星が綺麗だよあ本だ映らねえだろ
ギリギリ見て
映るのすごい
ね大声出しちゃだめよはいもちろんです
さっき家あったからねそうですね近所迷惑
にならないようにそうさすがに人が住んで
いる場所は良くないです
うんなんかこの赤外線的なやつでこうやっ
て見るとさカラコンしてるみたいだね
[音楽]
なんか髭のゾンビみたいねやなんでこと言
んだか髭のゾンビ
あなんかうん大きめの石がゴロゴロとうん
どのぐらいだそんな行ったっけ結構来てる
んじゃないですかもうちょっと真っすぐっ
ぽいっすねあほとこっち俺持とうかじゃえ
いいです
かありがとうございます助かりますあ鳥が
見え
た
ああれか
うんなんか壊れてませんね
え壊れちゃった壊ちゃった壊れちゃった
壊れちゃった壊れちゃったうんじゃ
行こう今ついたの見ました一瞬
うん
あつかなくなりましたあついたじゃ入り
ますよ鳥のり方分かってますかえ面は通ら
ないはいはい左側左側こ先行きますねお
願いします注してはい失礼いたします
はい
[音楽]
よいしょおうれた本当
だこまし
[音楽]
てわすごいこの木見
て中が
しかも
なんかなんかほら炭になっ
てる燃やし
たなんでなんですかね燃やしたのか雷ああ
なるほどなるほどい燃やしたあるねなこれ
以上なんか口ないように燃やしたのかな
失礼いたします
[音楽]
はい
失礼し
ますちゃんとあの幼いものというかして
あるね
うんでなんか聞いたんですけどうんこれの
裏に
うん大きい岩があるらしくてうんそれが
やばいっていう話を聞きましたやばいとは
いやなんかそういうなんか例が出るという
かおおなどちゃんとご挨拶するからじゃあ
またこれ持っといてもらっていいですか
はい分かりましたき
[音楽]
ます
私も行ってき
ますますじゃ後ろの方も行かせていただき
ますかそうですね裏の岩がそもそも本当に
あるかどうかをこれいけないな木がある
立派な本だあでも囲があっていうこと
は何かうんあるかもです
[音楽]
ね岩あここえ岩って感じでもないけどなで
も綺麗なほら深目が出ていますうんうん
うん
うんなんか岩っぽくはないですね
えどこ
だもしかしたらここに埋まってるのかな
何かがあここなんか階段ある
じゃんがいっぱいある本当
だこれ暗なのか
[音楽]
な
って感じじゃないねうん掃除とかを片が
する道だねなんかくらって言ってたんです
よ
[音楽]
ねあっちも行ってみていいですかどうぞ
行きましょうすいませんありがとうござい
ますうわ本当
だすごいゴミがうん置いてやるな
失礼します失礼し
ます道だねここねうん舗装されてるもん
ちゃんと道ですねあ多これ行くとね道路に
出るあそうなんですねうん普通のちょっと
一瞬電話してみてもいいですか
はい電波が
弱い
あもしもしあもしもしお疲れ様ですお疲れ
様です今最初うーって言いまし
た
え言ってないですよね言ってないです言っ
てないですそうですよねすいませんなんで
もないです聞こえたねちょっと待くさい
ちょっとどうしましたえあの大きい石って
どこにあるんですでしたっけ
えっとククみたいなそのいわゆる酒瓶とか
がめちゃめちゃ置いてあるらしいんです
けど坂瓶鳥くぐってた先に多分クがあ
るって言っててクってその鳥くぐった先に
クお酒をでも幼いもしてあったよああそこ
はいはいそれの裏ですね裏は岩というか
なんかかいしてあるんですけど岩とかは
ないすねなんか岩かなんかちょっとこう山
みたい
にっこりしてるみたいなあオッケーじゃあ
会ってますすいませんありがとうござい
ますその確認でしたお願いしますはい失礼
します
はい最初うーって言ってませんでしたね何
だったんだろうねあれあじゃあそこで合っ
てたんですね
[音楽]
うん
よしさ帰りましょううんあたらここかうん
というかねうんま鳥という鳥というか祠と
いうかうん本殿というのか
うん歴史っぽいうの書いてあると読めない
ね四天同寺と南本のま多分さっき調べたよ
ね書いてあったようなことだよねうんうん
うんでも特定の文字だけ赤くなってますね
ね板を持つ人々を助け
たいうんうん行きましょう行きましょう
はいじゃあ鳥のこちら側から出まして失礼
いたしましたありがとうござい
ます道が険しい木の根がねうん木は上に
生えている長さと同じ分だけの長さの
根っこがあるという
からさっきのううちょっとやでした気に
なったね何落ち
たあわしの携帯かありがとうはいという
わけで山田さんどどうでしたどうでし
たっていうのもあれですけど
うん
ああ何かねタイミングによって
は何か不思議なことが起きたりするのかも
しれないですねうんまあとこういうさよく
あるのをさこう普通にやっていたけども後
で編集した時に何か気づくみたいな
パターンもあるよね音とかそうですね
うんそれ多いんですよね知らない音入っ
てるとかマジで
うんとりあえずでもうんなせひとまず無事
に今帰り道なんですけどええでも鳥肌は
ずっと立ってるえ僕もなんですよ本当です
かうん
ほ
坂だっあ本当だ本当だ山田さん器具ですね
僕もですちょっと山田さんまた機会があり
ましたらはい行きましょうそうですねはい
すみにねすみにまもうもはやでも9月です
からはいま来年ですかね来年ですかね
え山田さんと定期的にまた会いたいです不
定期でいいんじゃないですかああちょっと
エッチですねいやそれちょっとあしいませ
ん間違えましたうん
はいなんだろうね今
の音なってません
なんか
ええ今聞こえました
[音楽]
うんなんだね音楽みたいに聞こえる
ねなんかオルゴールみたいな音楽だねああ
愉快な山ですねでもこっち山しかないっす
よ
ね帰りましょう山田さん普通に音楽がなっ
ているそうですよねあ前から誰か来てるえ
無理来て
ない目が悪いからさ俺あもですえ今何だっ
たんすかねオルゴール絶対だってこっち山
すようんりだ
ねオルゴールの音ではないなメロディそう
いう感じだけど俺これもっと金属音じゃん
ああキキもっと高いすうわいこれは完全
廃車だ
ね
こいやまあとりあえず
うん帰ります帰り
ましょう帰りましょうこっちだけ止めます
ねああ
[音楽]
怖いゆより怖いですね
元気な中年
です